this video we're going to begin the
derivation of the LC natural response
the response of a inductor capacitor
circuit this is a difficult derivation
but it really pays off in the end
there's a real fun surprise at the end
and that is this is where sine waves are
born we're gonna end up with sine waves
at the end of this and that's a that's a
really nice result because these are
everywhere in electronics and in the
natural world we're gonna start out by
saying we're going to put some some
charge on this capacitor here and we're
going to have the current in this
circuit I we're gonna have that start at
zero so I zero is zero but this is the
current through the through the circuit
and that means that that current is
exists over here as well let's put a
switch in this circuit
and we're gonna close that switch at T
equals zero so we have one variable one
variable is I and the other variable
we're going to use is V and V is this
voltage here after the switch closes so
we want to find I and V and for this
we're going to focus on finding finding
I once we find eyes it's straightforward
to find e so this is going to be our
independent variable is the current so
let's begin the analysis at the moment T
equals zero the charge that exists here
is going to start flowing in the circuit
and both voltage and current are going
to start to change
so let's write some expressions let's
start out by writing some things we know
that are true about our two components
and we'll start with the capacitor so
we'll start by writing a an expression
for our capacitor and there's a little
sign flip that happens here so we got to
be a little bit careful so if I have V
on a capacitor and I in a capacitor that
would I would say that I capacitor
equals C DV C DT now if we look here VC
is the same as V here positive sign at
the top positive sign at the top
negative sign at the bottom so VC and V
are the same but I we have to be careful
eye is in the opposite direction of the
vault the of the current that I picked
for our independent variable so that's
upside down so I there's that there's a
negative sign we get to flip here equals
negative c dv/dt
so that's the IV equation for our
particular circuit we have that little
extra negative sign and now I want to
write the the integral form of the
capacitor IV equation which is V equals
1 over C times the integral of I DT and
remember our minus sign this is the
important minus sign to bring along ok
so let's do the voltage across the
inductor the inductor voltage is the
same variable v is l di/dt
so there's no extra minus sign here this
is assigned according to the sign
convention for passive components so now
we have an expression for V on the
capacitor and we have an expression for
V on the inductor and we know that
that's the same voltage so let's set
these two things together so we can say
that L di DT equals minus 1 over C times
the integral of I DT all we did was set
the two identical voltage is equal to
each other and now I'm going to
manipulate this a bit it says that L di
DT plus 1 over C the integral of I DT
equals 0 we just gathered terms on one
side and we set the other side became 0
now since I'm not used to having
integrals inside equations I'd rather
have derivatives since I have some
experience with differential equations
let's if we take a derivative of this
whole equation so here's what we're
going to do we're going to take a
derivative with respect to time of this
whole thing here and that gives us we
get the second derivative of the first
term so we get L second derivative of i
with respect to time plus 1 over C and
then the derivative of the integral of I
DT turns into just I and the derivative
of zero on this side is zero so this is
now the differential equation for the LC
circuit and it's called it has a name is
called a second-order
homogeneous ordinary differential
equation it's a differential equation
because it has derivatives in it it's
homogeneous because it only has
derivatives of I with respect to T and
nothing else the indicator is that this
side is equal to zero there's no forcing
term over here on this side so when you
can write the equation this way we say
it's homogeneous and it's called a
second-order equation because it has
this second derivative right here so now
we've set up our second order
homogeneous oh de and in the next video
we'll go about solving this we're going
to go through it step by step